so this has been uh this has been really
fun not really fun actually it's been
something uh it's been something at
least i'll say that
that much at least i decided that
because because many of you
work at places with hr departments that
make you sit through
sensitivity training videos i should
both as a form of um
as an act of solidarity but also as a
form of sort of anthropological
research i decided i should subject
myself
to the same i found these videos on the
youtube channel of a company called m
train
which provides sensitivity training
material to a lot of big companies like
buzzfeed and live nation and i think new
york times bunch of companies
they use this company to give them their
sensitivity training material
so last time we watched uh their videos
on microaggressions
in the workplace and those were great
today we're going to take some time to
watch
some of their teaching videos on the
important issue of workplace
harassment this is an issue that's
very important to me um i am often
harassed here at my job for example the
other day i wanted to go brew some
coffee and uh and i went to the cabinet
where the coffee filters are supposed to
be and there was no coffee filters i
actually had to walk
to a different cabinet to get them so i
considered that to be in a way
a form of harassment maybe even a
microaggression i don't know
i'm not sure if m train would say that
harassment or not but we'll find out so
let's start here here's a video
this one is on inappropriate touching
sounds pretty frisky we'll uh we'll take
a look and
see what we find out
great so pull the numbers from last year
and plug them into the report
and then distribute it before we meet
with christine tomorrow okay absolutely
i can do that
oh last late night just in time i need
to get back to the gym
me too my back is killing me it's like
there's a knife between my shoulders
have you tried a yoga roller worked for
me that doesn't do any good
there's really only one thing okay this
is already heading bad places
but i see where this is this is setting
up and uh i i
i feel like i know where this is going
you know
i hate to ask but would you would you
walk on my back
walk on your back i mean no i i mean i'd
hurt you
my daughter does it all the time really
it's the only thing that helps i'd
really appreciate it no
i can't do that no come on it'll take
two minutes it'll really help me out
ah come on i don't think i should do
this
help me out
ah there you go ah that's just stuff
that's it right there right there right
there oh
okay i have to tell you i i didn't i
thought i knew where it was going it
i didn't expect that that's not where i
thought so that was a there was a twist
ending
at the end there kind of an m night
shyamalan twist ending
so i have questions number one is this
really a common problem in the american
office environment i admit i haven't
worked in you know i was working from
home for years i haven't worked in an
office environment that much
um i haven't seen anybody walking on
anybody's back here i can report is this
a common thing that comes up a lot
because i've never heard this in my life
i could just be naive do women often get
approached
by men at work asking them to walk on
their backs
what other weird requests do you get
like hey listen hate to ask would you
mind uh hitting me in the shins with a
crowbar
would you mind it would really help me
out thanks a lot i appreciate it
uh i don't know this this seems like
kind of a niche grievance
this seems way too specific i just
imagine the brainstorming session
at m train when they were deciding on
their next harassment skit
and somebody was like oh i know let's do
one where someone wants a lady to walk
on their back
yeah let's do that one dude you're
telling on yourself
a little bit calm down this isn't very
professional
the second point though is why did she
do it
see this is always a problem i have even
some of the the me too stories that you
hear about and i you know this is a me
too this is a me
this this woman this is a me too right
now we're watching a me too happen
but why did you do it you could tell she
was she was very uncomfortable
and she's looking traumatized as she's
walking on the dude's back
just walk out of the room if you're
gonna walk just keep keep walking
out of the room walk over his back out
of the room
and then go tell someone and say hey
this freak in there is laying on the
ground
begging me to walk on him call the
police
i that i don't understand it you know i
kind of feel like
if you're a woman in the workplace
someone asked you to do that and you
actually
do it then you're just as much to blame
as he is
if i'm the boss i'd fire you both for
being a bunch of weirdos
if i walk into the room and see that
you're both gone
i don't care that the woman has a
troubled expression
i don't know if i should be doing get
out of here you both your freaks
get a hotel room if you're gonna do that
don't do it here
um all right so that one i just uh i
don't know what to think about that one
but let's go let's move on this one is
about
workplace gender discrimination
big issue really important issue let's
watch
are you bringing anything for safety
yeah i have a taser okay
are you flying into dulles or reagan
baltimore ticket prices were insane yeah
i use miles
and this is history though you know i
mean our grandkids will be able to say
my granny
walked in the women's march i know it
feels super important
were you guys serious is this some kind
of a joke
so lindsay do you want to grab dinner
that first night
great wait a minute you guys are going
to participate in some sort of a
cockamamie
march to try to change things okay rick
i know that you don't care about women
or their rights you've made that
abundantly clear but i do
you know rick if you and all the people
like you had half a brain or any
compassion
we wouldn't be in this mess okay i i'm
not sure who is supposed to be guilty of
harassment or
discrimination there that's probably a
bad sign
it i i feel like i'm i'm probably
supposed to know when i watch these
videos who the bad guy is
i can't really tell to me it's obviously
the women they're the bad guys because
this guy is awesome
i want to work with this guy he's just
he's a straight edge dude and you know
you could tell he's a dad wearing his
khakis and a little bit of a ned
flanders vibe he's got a sweater on
and he's directing to the point let's
come come on with your cockamamie march
better skedaddle out of here with that
no more guff out of you two wise acres
so i appreciate that the women are the
ones who come on
way too strong and they're basically
exactly the sort of women who would go
to a women's march so i believe that
part of it
but if i'm making a determination here
and i'm watching that or if
again if i'm the boss and i'm deciding
who gets fired in this interaction
definitely the two women first of all
what are you doing putting
flyers for a political march up at work
and second this man is just trying to
engage with you he's given his opinion
and you cut him down like that he's the
victim here
all right finally this is getting a
little confusing maybe it's hard to keep
track of everything so fortunately
they've got a video that makes it simple
with color coordination so here's one
and it is
explaining the workplace
color spectrum so i think the idea here
is that
all of the the bad behavior at work is
on is color-coded
and so this will just make it easier for
you when you're at work to know
if you're behaving badly or not let's
check this out
the workplace color spectrum let's talk
about how this handy tool works
the color spectrum uses four colors to
reflect four categories of workplace
conduct
from positive and empowering to
completely
unacceptable when we're talking about
green conduct
we're talking about conduct that is
deliberately respectful
socially aware and able to see things
from someone else's point of view
green doesn't come easily but it's what
we all aim for
now yellow behavior isn't deliberate
it's
reactive insensitive and sometimes rude
it's what happens when you snap at a
co-worker or make a thoughtless remark
yellow conduct isn't unlawful but it can
cause workplace drama
let's look at orange orange looks a lot
like yellow but with a big difference
orange conduct is aimed at protected
characteristics
that includes things like gender age
race and religion one orange act
isn't illegal but it can make people
feel excluded or treated
unfairly and left unchecked it can turn
red and unlawful
and what is red conduct rut conduct is
aimed at protected characteristics too
but it's unlawful because it's more
frequent or more severe
okay i have to say and i i just have to
admit this i don't know if i should
admit this publicly but i'm usually
living
in yellow zone that's where i live uh
that's that's me probably most of the
time insensitive and rude but not
unlawful
so that's where i'm at basically all of
my conduct just throughout life
my approach to life uh but fortunately i
guess i can't get
fired for it right because i could
always say hey i'm in the yellow okay
i'm good
you can't you can't get me this is
yellow this is all yellow right now
but for orange and red my question is
what the hell
is a protected characteristic what kind
of term is that
i would rather be targeted by like i
would rather be
attacked for my age gender or race
and those are supposedly the protected
characteristics um than for who i am as
a person
and what about like um what about other
what about height
is that a protected characteristic can i
make fun of someone i'm a taller guy can
i make fun of short people
um i assume weight so weight is probably
protected you can't laugh at someone for
being fat
uh what about hair if somebody has less
hair then then i do can i make fun if
they have more hair than i do
can they make fun of me i mean how does
this all work
nobody knows and they don't really
explain it i guess we'll need to get
another video where they explain they
lay out some of that
uh and this is all why i guess i
continue to be glad that i don't have to
sit through these
videos though i am choosing to right now
of my own volition
what that says about my own mental
health
is up for you to decide